大家好
这里是人度解说
AI绘图圈终于赢了一件大事
最强的图片生成模型
Eden Ground 4官方正式开源了
而且直接放出了模型权重
它是目前最接近GPT Image
和Midginning的开源图片生成模型
而且在所有开源的图片模型中
Eden Ground 4以绝对优势
领先于其他开放模型
而且更重要的是
它可以完全本地部署
人人都能安装使用
目前官方开放的模型主要有两个
分别是NF4精度的全重量化版
它卓用于N卡上
支持扩张
还有另外一个是FP8精度版
它可以在任何硬件上进行部署运行
两个模型都是9.3B的
别看只有90亿参数量
在目前所有开源的独变生成模型中
A.GLF拥有最好的文版渲染效果
领先于200亿参数的轻微Image
或者是321亿参数的Flash 2
哪怕是800亿参数量的回源Image数类
也没法跟它比
那么它到底有没有这么强
普通电脑能不能跑
接下来我们进行本地部署进行完整实测下
在开始之前
首先我们需要打开里路博上这篇文章
链接我会放在视频下方
打开以后接往下拉
上面我们接索的全部资料
首先第一步
我们需要把这开源模型给它当下来
上面总共有五个文件我们需要进行下载一下
分别是主模型和扩散模型
还有文购编码器等等
到时候我会把这五个模型文件给大家打包一下
方便下载
到时给它当下来就可以了
全部下载好以后
到时给它放到对应的文件夹下
就是ConfiUI
如果电脑上没有安装ConfiUI的话
那么现在我们来执行第二步
就是来安装一下最新版本的ConfiUI客户动
如果你是老版本的话
那么一定要把它升级在最新版本
那进行安装一下
或者覆盖安装就可以了
那么提前往打开它
进行安装一下
好 打开以后
那么底下边有个download的按钮
给它倒下来
总共是150多兆左右
我们给它放在桌面上
那么底下载
好 下载好以后
然后进行安装一下
来把这最新版本的ConfiUI客户动
进行安装一下
我们点下一步
它默认是安装C版的
当然可以放其他版幅
点安装
如果缺乏相应的组件的话
它会提醒你安装
安装好以后我们点击完成
安装好以后它会自动启动
然后它问你如何进行运行这个ConfiUI
第一个是云端客户端然后第二个是本地因为是本地安装所以就选第二个就可以了这样我们可以完全控制来使用硬件进行跑这个config UI然后在下方这里有一个同意它侨款协议勾选上
师傅分享这个匿名数据
这个你可以勾选或不勾选都可以
基本第一继续
然后最后他有个提示
他问你师傅启用中国镜像
他说你的语言看起来是中文的
如果你在中国的话
那么建议启用中国镜像
来进本地部署
而不是通过GuyHub进行部署
所以如果你在中国大陆的话
那么进行启用这个镜像
安装会更快
也无需翻墙就会进行下载
因为我不在国内
所以我就不用启用这个镜像了
我写账簿就可以了
然后这次它让我配置一下
Konfi也可不得
这个名称化也可以自定一下
比如输入零度
然后在下方这里
它检测到GPU了
我当前是N卡
如果是A卡的话
它也会识别
然后在下方这里
它有个安装位置
它默认是放在C盘上
你可以自定义放在其他盘幅
然后在下方这里
它有一个高级选项
目前推荐是安装独立版本
会更加稳定
当前最稳定版本是这个V0.26.2这个版本
然后硬件当前选择是N卡
当然如果你是A卡的话
你就选上面这个
或者是I卡的话
选下面这个都可以
CPU化也可以
如果是从CPU化就速度比较慢了
我自己选择N卡
选择好以后就我们的地区续
然后最后它问我们
是否需要导入工作流
第一个是ZImageTourable
第二个是One 2.1
这个我们先不用管它
我们先跳过并安装
好 这样它正式开始下载了
我们下载一会
这个下载安装办法
总共大概是两G左右
好 当它安装完成以后
然后现在我们重新返回了钢铁线
来下载这个工作流
把这个工作流给它担下来
我们点下载
好 下载好工作流以后
然后现在直接拖到这个comby.com
拖进来
拖进去好以后
我们看一下它上面会显示
缺少四个索区模型
然后下面点上边有一个
显示缺失的模型
大家看一下
这四个模型其实我们刚才已经下载好了
就刚才我们在第一步下载好这五个模型文件
下面只需要把它放在对应的文件夹下就可以了
我们来看一下
模型文件结构是这样的
我们打开我们的SAPE
然后打开用户文件夹
进入以后
然后这里面找到自己的用户名
比如我是零路的文件夹
打开它
然后打开以后
那么地上边有一个查看
我们需要把隐藏项目给它显示出来
地上边有显示
展开以后找到里面有一个隐藏项目
这时没看到
它里面就会出现一个APP data的文件夹
就这里了
打开它
打开以后找到里面有个Local文件夹
就这个了
好 这时候没看到它里面有个Conv以外Desktop文件夹打开它进入以后我们打开第三个文件夹打开它这时候我们看到它里面有个modus文件夹了然后在这个modus文件夹里
按这个存储位置
把对应的模型文件
放到对应的文件夹下就可以了
或者如果你之前没下载模型的话
那么就点上方有个全部下载按钮
来进行在线下载也是可以的
它会自动把模型下载对应的文件夹下
就不需要通过手动配置了
但是如果你在中国大陆的话
通过这种在线下载
你可能需要进行科学上网才可以
否则的话它肯定是没法下载的
所以如果你没法在线下载
那你通过我们刚才的手动方式
把对应模型文件
放到对应文件夹下就可以了
好 大家全部下载完成以后
现在就可以进行使用了
我们刷新一下就可以了
那现在把它工作流给它隐藏掉
在那的话就可以进行使用了
左边第一个就可以设置宽高比的
就独别深圳比例
像9比16或16比9都是可以的
到时候你可以自由选择
然后这里的话是放入提示词的地方
当你放入好以后
那么你上边运行
就可以进行深圖了
这个生成过程还是非常快的
接下来试一下
比如我们先使用这个魔法提示值
来进行生成一下
把提示给快配出来
好 复制好以后
我先把它粘定进来
我们放到第一个这个速度框这里
贴进来就可以了
速度好以后
然后其他不用管它了
当然你可以制定这个框架笔
比如我们可以把这个框架笔设置为16p9的
好 设置好以后
然后再点击运行
来试一下
当上方显示是绿框的话
那说明它已经开始了
稍等一会
这个速度还是挺快的
我当前是24G的显存
生成一个图片的话
大概需要5秒钟左右
大家看一下
它立马就完成了
大家看一下效果
非常真实
或者你也可以优化题词
来进行生成
好多人觉得它有很多限制
这主要是因为你当前
题词下的不对
因为好多关键词
不能直接明硕
你可以通过另外一种方式
来进行表达
你想生成怎么样的图片的话
那么这个题词词的关键词
你可以自己下
大家看一下
再生成一些小幻穷
我们放在看一下
这个图片的生成细节
相当可以
现在大家帮我生成一个功夫熊魔理的Panda
试一下
如果想对图片进行精细控制的话
那么进行通过它官方要求的这种交参格式
它生成效果会更好
大家看一下
一马就完成了
大家看一下效果
是不是跟动画片里特别像
一字搞定
这它帮我生成一个考通式的狗狗
现在我们来测试一下
通过中文这个节词看行不行
把它删掉输入一个比较简单的就在夜色下有一个人在泡温泉我们先把框框比改成超大幅的就21比9的来看效果怎么样我们底下运行
这样可以直接生成
大家看一下
它这个色彩比例
还有打光的角度
都看得像是真能拍摄一样
还有天空 满天繁星
还有四周的环境
做得非常真实
同时还测试另外一个
也是用中文的生成
就在雪原森林之中
放着一支神级的天气屏
我们来看效果
只要几秒钟立马就搞定
大家看一下
像这个玻璃球的雪花晶片
还有雪地上反射的太阳光
设计的为面为强
非常的好看
通过刚才测试
我觉得这款开源模型
相比之前的那些模型的话
它生成图片的速度不仅更快
关键是更加自然
更加真实
现在我们再来试一个动漫卡通图片
这次我们同时通过这个Judson提示词
进行优化
让它生成更详细的细节
大家看一下可以的
立马可以完成
如果本马一的话
它可以继续生成
因为它是完全本地的
你需要生成什么图片的话
那就输入对应的关键词就可以了
经过我测试
用英文提示词比用中文提示词更好
最主要是跟这个模型训练数据有关
到时候把这个图片生成提示词放到零度泊上
如果需要的话可以自己去获取
如果是做插画的或者动画设计
产品设计图
那么你都可以通过这模型来进生成
效果确实非常不错
但它也有不足的地方
比如现在我帮我制作一个流程图
让它演示一下西红柿草剂当的一个步骤
用图片来演示
大家看一下
它另外一把就搞定了
我们现在主要来看一下
它这中文有没有出错的
看到了大家看一下
在第三步和第四步
它就出错了
这两个字可以错了
看一下
但它整个步骤还是可以的
第一个是把这个饭机洗干净
切块
然后煎鸡蛋
炒鸡蛋
然后炒出鸡蛋以后
最后把这个鸡蛋跟西红柿一块炒
步骤没问题
但是中文字体
它还是有少部分是出错的
这个模型对这个英文理解
还是比较好一点
对中文的制作
还稍微缺点火候
最后呢
帮我生成一个高端大气的广告图
这个是比较实用的
大家看一下
另外搞定了
打开效果
相当的nice
看着非常中业且大气
好 今天的视频
手用的全部资料
他们下载链接
我都放在视频下方
这个博物赞
by bwd6